when was the moment you said
holy was it was it the Letterman
finally being on Letterman was it you
know your first special was it your
first book you know what was the what
was that moment where you thought
you did it Jim you went
against the grain you did it your own
way here you are
and you said hey and you could
appreciate what you had done and really
um kind of just said
nice job
I mean there was uh
there was a couple moments
it's I mean Letterman was
like I remember thinking okay I can
because you know what in that era
and and as an actor or a comedian
when you would tell people
you're an actor or comedian
they'd be like have you been on anything
and if you had nothing to say they would
look at you like
um and so I knew once I did Letterman
I had won that argument so I was a real
comedian that that was a measuring stick
there was my personal measuring stick
and the measuring stick that I
encountered like people used to be like
you should go on The Tonight Show it's
like it's not like I haven't thought
right
I would say that there's moments where
I mean I'm sure it's the same for you
like there's moments where
I also
I don't whenever you think you got to
figure it out you don't you're I mean
it's so but I would say that there are
moments where I'm like oh wow this is
nice like for me I felt like
you know I mean I even feel like when
Dave Attell told me he thought I was
funny like that's a huge thing that was
a long time ago too wasn't it yeah and
then like doing Dr Katz I was like oh
that's actually a show I want to watch
yeah and
but I think there was also
um you know when I was it's so funny
because like I uh
I was doing stand up and I had had
different managers and
um you know like there's no rules for
like managing a career I remember I was
talking to
Ed Helms about this he's like there's no
internship on how to deal with like oh
you're you're and it's not about money
it's about like oh here's what you
should do because there's no
no one's had the exact same experience
but there's
there's a moment where
um
I remember I was touring doing stand-up
again I had a lot of
uh you know I had done Welcome to New
York I had done the Allen Show I had you
know like the acting the stand the
sitcom acting thing
it's it's weird because like
the
again it's like what happens in my life
I feel like this is a therapy session
what it is
what what happens in my life is
I have to learn things over and over
again and so the one of the things I
constantly fall into the Trap of is
getting caught up in other people's
expectations yeah so
in my
parents expectations nothing malicious
but they're like success is wearing a
coat and tie so I spent up until my 20s
success is wearing a coat and tie I'm
going to do that I'm going to work coat
and tie that's how you get happy right
and so
the whole thing is is when I did
Letterman and then I got Welcome to New
York and then I got on Ellen uh the
Ellen second show
I was
doing the sitcom route and then I was on
That 70s Show and Ed I did we occurred
on Ed and I remember thinking
like even if you know that 70s Show was
so big at the time but I remember
thinking
well this isn't that fun